(upbeat electronic music)
- This looks like something
that a My Little Pony would drink.
- There are bits in here
that I want to get out.
What is this, is this coconut?
- Uhhh?
- (slurps)
- That's like creamy and it's icy.
- It's got this like
rosy island feel to it.
(upbeat electronic music)
Oh my God!
- (sighs and laughs)
- This is very like typical Asian fare
of just eating an entire fish.
- I've never had fish served with a head.
- I don't mind that the
fish is served whole.
In fact I actually prefer it.
- All the flavors have seeped into it.
It was probably cooked over
some kind of open fire.
- It tastes like it just came straight
out of a barbecue.
This is awesome.
(upbeat electronic music)
- That's delicious, it's
like a peanut sauce salad.
- Some eggs, it's good to have
some protein with your salad.
(crackers cracking)
- Mmmm! It's a prawn cracker!
- There's other things underneath here.
- It's like a bitter egg cracker.
- I like this kind of stuff.
What are you doing?!
No it's okay. (laughs)
(upbeat electronic music)
- Whoa! Indonesian food
is blowing my mind!
- Anything with rice and
fried-ness I get so excited about.
- This fried rice tastes a little sweeter
than the fried rice I normally eat.
- Kind of shrimpy, it smells
like fish sauce maybe.
- It's not too oily or greasy.
- Super flavorful.
(upbeat electronic music)
Yes! Noodles!
- This looks like chow mein.
- I think this is my new
favorite food type, Indonesian.
- What is the history of Indonesia
that all these foods are so blended.
- It's not greasy, I love it.
- When the egg is like darker
brown from all the sauce
like really like
marinated into it you know
it's going to be like
super-flavorful and good.
- It is so, oh my God.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Beef randand, beef randang.
- A meat pile has appeared in front of me.
- I looked at it and I was
kind of skeptical and nervous.
But it tastes amazing.
- Coconut and meat and like, chili?
- There's lots of spices
and herbs in here.
- I feel like it needs some
of those prawn crackers
or something to just really get in there
and just get every little nook and cranny.
- This would be delicious over rice.
- Why have I never had this food before?
How have I lived so long
and never had this food?
- I was super impressed at
the diversity of flavor.
- It was really delicious,
it was just so surprising.
- It's very rustic, it's very flavorful.
- It's like everything I like from
international cuisines put into one.